>>Student: Hello, Doctor Greb.
>>Student: Hello, Cora.
>>Narrator: These students
at New Jersey's Montclair State
University are practicing a
classroom greeting.
>>Man: Hello, Laura.
Now do I-- ?
>>Narrator: It's part of the fun
and excitement of becoming the kind
of teacher the school describes
in its portrait of a teacher.
>>Ada: One of the things
that sets us apart is
that we do have a very clear vision
for what we believe constitutes good
teaching and learning and schooling.
>>Teacher: So why do activities
in your classroom like this?
>>Ada: Learning to teach takes place
over the course of an entire career,
and what we are committed to
do is to prepare our students
to be excellent beginning teachers
who know how to continue to learn
and grow and develop as teachers.
>>Teacher: Everyone look at
me, everyone give me the sign.
>>Narrator: Montclair
has developed a network
of some twenty-five partner school
districts in the area, where students
like Andrea Mayernick can get their
first exposure to the classroom.
>>Andrea: They really push
hands on, jump right in there,
get your feet wet,
because in the end,
that's where you need
the most experience.
You learn the most from practice.
>>How many hops till twenty?
>>Narrator: Mayernick student
teaches at Bradford Elementary School
with her cooperating
teacher, Serena Swain.
>>Serena: You're going to
guess or take an estimate
of how many pennies you
can grab with your hand.
>>Andrea: I'm in the first grade
with Miss Swain and it's just been
such an amazing experience to
just interact with the children
on a daily basis and
to be with Miss Swain.
She's an amazing mentor.
>>Serena: I don't know if this
surface is really good for grabbing,
so maybe use a slate
or a book, something.
>>Andrea: The preparation, I need,
and it's really given me the
confidence that when I take
over my own classroom, I can do this.
I'm capable, and I can do it well.
>>Fran: You can't learn how to
teach in a vacuum and reading
about teaching in a
book, watching a video,
albeit might be very interesting
and helpful, you've gotta roll
up your sleeves and
you've gotta get into it.
We want them to see the complexity of
what it means to be in a classroom.
>>Joe: And let's count back fourteen.
>>Student teaching,
well, it's a journey.
I sped a lotta time at home
doing lesson plan preparation.
I observe my cooperating
teacher a lot, trying to pick
up on her style of teaching.
>>Who could tell me what
these are, [inaudible].
It's something just like this, only--
>>And all the support
that Montclair State has
to offer has been great too, because
you need a lot of support for this.
>>So what numbers do
we have to subtract?
>>Naomi: One of the things I'm trying
to teach Joe is, sometimes you have
to be flexible within your planning,
and so I let him see my
lesson plans as well.
They're certainly not as
thought out and as detailed,
because you just don't have the time.
If I spent three hours planning every
lesson, you know, I'd have no life.
>>Fran: Your lesson was
incredibly well planned.
>>Narrator: Once a week, student
teachers meet with their professor
and cooperating teacher to get
feedback on their progress.
>>Naomi: You know, aside
from the emotional benefits
and positive feedback that you
gave to them, when you're talking
about difference, maybe write the
actual number model on the board.
So instead of-- and explain what
that is, that you're subtracting
from the higher number
to the lower number--
>>Joe: I go home at the
end of the day smiling,
even though I'm stressed out, even
though I know I still have an hour
or two at home planning,
I feel good about it.
>>Who can tell me what a mile is?
>>Man: So using this panel
right here, we have control
over the whole room, so we
can turn the lights down--
>>Narrator: As part of their
emphasis on technology,
Montclair created several classrooms
of the future where students
and recent graduates can try
out tech-infused lessons.
>>Man: This controls
everything in the classroom.
Now I'm actually gonna put it
up on the vacuuming camera,
so you can see what we're looking at.
>>Ada: And when our graduates
are out in the schools,
they're always welcome to bring
a class here, if they don't have
that capacity in their school.
And we work with the teachers
in our partner schools as well,
so that their comfort level goes up.
>>Man: Okay, so you're gonna vote on
which president you wanna research,
and each student's gonna
come up with one clue.
>>Narrator: To play an
historical WebQuest game,
this fifth grade class was divided
into two adjoining classrooms
that were linked by a teleconference.
>>Teacher: So where do you
think might be a good place
to start searching for
information on James K. Polk?
>>Student: Google.
>>Teacher: Great place to
start, what do you think?
>>Student: You would
do Wikipedia too,
because it has a lot
of the information.
>>Teacher: Yes, yes--
>>Ada: People will often say,
"Aren't you teaching your students
about technology that
they're not gonna have access
to when they actually go
out in the classrooms?"
That may be true to some
extent but what we've found
and what the research shows is
that there's a lot more technology
in schools than teachers
actually know how to make use of.
The students may, but the
teachers are not that adept.
>>Teacher: Okay, so we are going
to come up and read our clues.
>>Student: He only served
on term as President.
>>Student: He lost an election
in the early nineteen hundreds.
>>Ada: By raising our students'
comfort level with trying
out new things and with doing
different things, they learn how
to have their students create blogs.
They learn how to teach
their students
to make digital stories,
as a literacy strategy.
So they're not intimidated
by what's there.
>>Teacher: All right, so
our guess for President,
we're gonna say it all together.
>>All: James Polk.
>>Ada: And then we hope that they
will advocate for more technology
in the schools that they teach in.
>>Amanda: We're a lot more
concerned with getting
through the curricular
goals and standards.
>>Narrator: Montclair believes that
new teachers need to be prepared
to face the challenges of
their profession head on,
and when necessary, become
advocates for change.
>>Fran: Teachers have
to have a voice.
Right now, standardized
tests are a reality.
The question is, how
do we deal with them?
Yes, we do have to prepare the
students for some of the tests,
but we also have the obligation
to advocate for something
that we think may or
may not be appropriate.
>>Teacher: So I think [inaudible]
would be going for all students.
>>Narrator: In the school's
urban teaching academy,
students study everything
from culturally responsive curriculum
design to school finance issues.
>>Ana: What I'm hearing, you're
taking a political strategy.
>>Right.
>>Ana: We can't change
it all overnight.
There's going to be political
resistance to it, and that's part
of the struggle with
equalizing funding.
>>It's important for them to
not only see the problems,
but begin to envision possibilities
for bringing about change.
And in order to be an agent of change
in schools, you have to be informed.
If you don't know how
schools are funded,
if you don't know how monies are
distributed, you cannot put pressure
and act in ways to bring about
the changes that are needed.
>>Teacher: I will never be, you know,
absolutely ready, because teaching is
like this never ending journey--
>>Narrator: At weekly
support group meetings,
the student teachers learn
to lean on one another.
>>Fran: A lot of times, new teachers
are reluctant to ask for help,
because they think that it
doesn't bode well for them,
they should know everything.
And we wanna let them know that you
can't know everything, you know,
and how to get assistance
when you need it.
>>Teacher: The last thing
would be, what's the difference
between what you estimated
and what you actually got.
>>Ada: I don't believe that
good teachers are born.
I believe that we educate
people to become good teachers.
Students come to us already with
a love of learning, and our job is
to help them translate that love
of learning and a desire to work
with children or young
adolescents and a desire
to make a difference in society.
We need to take that and develop
it into a person who has the skills
and the strategies and the
knowledge to achieve that,
because it isn't so easy.
It's actually quite difficult.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org